Speaker 1: Let's go to Lucas from Brazil.
Brazil, of course, will have a runoff
election on October 30th and things are
quite wild there. Lucas, what's going on?
Speaker 4: Hello. Do you listening?
Speaker 1: I can hear you.
Speaker 4: So I want to ask you about voodoo. You
made it two months ago about Christian accused
assassination attempt. Do you remember that video?
Speaker 1: I do.
Speaker 4: Well, it's kind of hard.
Okay, so let's see. Don't you think
it was a bit conspiratorial at the video?
Speaker 1: Yes. I admit that in the video.
Speaker 4: I mean, even the right wing media in
Brazil, they hate Argentina. They think it's like
far left to be with Lenin saying that they mean
it seems like you you did some Clinton body count.
But Christine, the body count, Tony.
Speaker 1: Yeah, listen, I mean,
I say in the video, it could absolutely be
perceived that way. It's it's just you know,
I'm not pointing fingers at anyone in particular.
Just the entire thing stinks to high heaven. And
I it's certainly not a unique you know Argentinian
media have have suggested it and yeah but I say in
the video it's conspiratorial without a doubt.
Speaker 4: Do I think that's a problem? It's
breaking news and breaking news
coverage in general. You don't have
enough information so long for Israel.
Speaker 1: I didn't have anything to do
with it being breaking. I still have the same
opinion today. I mean, and now it's you know,
it's been two months, so. I don't know.
Speaker 4: But you still think that
it was kind of a fake flag today or.
Speaker 1: I think it's completely plausible.
This is one of the most corrupt people in the
history of Argentinean politics, on the cusp of
very serious evidence being presented against her.
And I would put nothing past her morally for sure.
Speaker 4: Okay. So I guess you
just a bit bite the bullet on
that conspiratorial stuff. I guess I'm.
Speaker 1: Biting the bullet. Yep. The
frogs are turning gay and everything.
Speaker 4: You know, for one little
question about running kids to see voting, do you
think it's a good path forward, though? I mean,
what do you have on the take on it?
Speaker 1: Yes, I have a dozen videos
about this where I including go through the
different forms of it, single transferable vote
and others. And generally speaking, some version
of ranked choice voting is very appealing to me.
Speaker 4: I see. Oh, well, I guess
that was my question. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, Lucas. Thank you. And who do
you support in the upcoming election, by the way.
Speaker 4: In the second round of voting,
that first a politician named Ciro Gomez,
that didn't go very well.
Speaker 1: Okay,
fair enough. But Lula in the south.
All right. Well, we're going to be
watching it closely, my friend.
Speaker 4: Good. Good. Thanks.
Speaker 1: There's Lucas from Brazil with
a very, very important election upcoming